yo blue lighthead podcast
we're live in buffalo right now
man first time in the city too this guy
showed me a lot of hospitality today
conway yeah yeah
yeah conway the new album or album
whatever we're calling this
next friday yeah next friday we're just
calling that great music
man i'm i'ma [ __ ] up the pronunciation
i'm gonna try la
masina close that that'll do
that was close enough la maquina my
mockiness see
i might be saying it wrong i think you
might be i'm trying to say
the machine wait we got a mexican in the
house he's saying it right
okay okay all right mexican approved
shout out my guy cook
shout out to my guy nah uh yo i mean
[ __ ] you just dropped this [ __ ] with a
with ghosts
this year already yeah man project
number two
yeah you know no i can't be still
man you know what i'm saying you know
idle hands is the devil's workshop
man so i try to you know
stay busy man my son texted me in the
middle of the interview and shout out to
bootleg kev jr yeah yeah um yeah it's
crazy because that's kind of been your
guys is in like the whole camps entire
like
approach to the game right it's just
non-stop pressure
like from the jump like and and now the
fans almost expect
you know you guys have more output than
most artists especially you like you
know what i'm saying like we get a lot
of conway music
um is it come easy like like i know
you've been like for example the shady
records album
i know it's been it's been done or a
version of it has been done for a while
yeah it's been done for like maybe
probably like a year so yeah yeah close
to a year two years
close to two years honestly damn [ __ ]
been done
um but um it do come easy to me because
like
you know i'm i'm i'm not in there really
like going to the club and going out and
partying and
you know [ __ ] off and a bunch of the
other [ __ ] like
i find my my fun and my excitement in
the day is
you know creating a new song or just
being around music and being in the
studio
so i was like you know it definitely
come easy for me but lately it ain't
been coming easy for me man honestly
i've been having like some kind of like
writer's block or just
not i don't know if it's just writer's
block or is it just like
you know what i'm saying it's like i'm
kind of getting bored with this whole
[ __ ]
kind of i needed a new challenge so
that's why i started this drum work [ __ ]
i needed to do find something else to
challenge myself and push myself
um you know to just keep
killing [ __ ] man and so i hadn't been
recording to answer your question
and been kind of like it ain't been easy
like last [ __ ] i recorded
before i started working on this tape
was um
i want to say um
the stefan dig song off the from king to
a god deluxe
mm-hmm and i was in like december you
know what i'm saying like
so you kind of been taking like a couple
months a couple months off we've been
kicking it not recording
i haven't been recording i haven't been
really been doing that and
maybe you know here and there
sporadically but i haven't really been
really into it all like that
like i've been just kind of chilling and
kind of like
you know trying to you know uh
detach myself from music i hadn't really
been listening to music and none of that
[ __ ] all like that like i just
did you find that that kind of tv did
that like help like with with kind of
refreshing your
enthusiasm yeah it did man sometimes you
gotta
you know what i'm saying you gotta take
a step back to take two forward
you know what i'm saying and you know
sometimes you got a more [ __ ] um
uh d program so you can reprogram
you know what i'm saying so i i kind of
needed that man i needed to just kind of
because i was just so
hard-pressed on you know like
i just wanted to i just wanted i just
wanted so bad like i just want to be the
best
i want people considering me like one of
the eldest like they would talk about
you know whoever in their top fives
right right right right be in that
conversation and
then i just you know i just overthink
[ __ ] a lot
and you know i'm saying especially like
i get the feeling like
slighted and [ __ ] like being left off
list and
if i'm not number one on such as this
[ __ ] list or that [ __ ]
like i just over and then that [ __ ] just
was kind of like just
you know what man let me just fall back
for a second because it's like
i feel like i'm insane some of the like
the early [ __ ]
man the other [ __ ] like [ __ ] is coming
with but it's like i agree
if it ain't you know what i mean i mean
you had this conversation
i mean you had this conversation when
there was that uh best verse of the year
conversation and
no one talked about the verse you had on
the the
the uh the fire in the booth [ __ ] yeah
which is like one of the heart
i revisit that freestyle i feel like
once once a week like
yeah well [ __ ] them they idiots anyway
what do they know
yeah i mean i do feel like though last
year you got a lot of love on a lot of
lists when it came to
the best album of the year yeah and i
appreciate the love too
and i appreciate it i feel like people
were giving you your flowers last year
you know what i'm saying i need that i
needed that man and i needed to still
like you know this is the [ __ ] that
drives me you know what i'm saying being
left off list
you know what i'm saying being second or
third or
fifth or not on the list like that's the
[ __ ] that
you know i i pay attention to everything
i just don't respond to everything
and even if even and sometimes i do
respond to it but that don't mean it's
like a response like
a comment or or
verbal response it's me i respond by
going
the studio and all right i'm gonna show
y'all show
these [ __ ] that's how i do that's
always been my attitude with everything
and um you know like i said like you
said like [ __ ] been giving me my roses
and all i respect that man
right i just i just appreciate um
i need a battery in my back to just you
know to just strive for more and
that's what i'm always striving for to
be better
every day kind of like i feel like it's
like tom brady type [ __ ] right like i
feel like tom brady gets
so much juice from everyone every year
talking about
he's falling off or whatever the [ __ ]
like it's really some sports type [ __ ]
like
some of the greats like are when they're
doubted or
second guessed that's how they that's
how they perform best you know what i'm
saying
right see like you know
having sex like like fear
of of not making it and not right taking
them there
drove me it drives me more than
you know because it's like i don't want
to let people down i don't want to let
myself down
i don't want to let my [ __ ] down my
family down my son's down
so it's like i i kind of like
when people just not you know in my mind
giving me more flowers or just like you
know
respecting this [ __ ] like it it make me
go even crazier so you said earlier you
were like yo
i go like i obsess because i want it all
i want to be considered in those
conversations right
so i feel like that's almost and you say
you also pay attention to everything
so i feel like if you pay attention to
everything it'll be kind of hard for you
to like
come to peace with like because no one
not everyone's going to feel like you
are in their top five or whatever you
know what i mean exactly
so it could either drive you crazy you
could already you know what if that or
it could keep fueling you you know what
i mean because
even if that's i mean you know not to
cut you off but that's that's
the that's um the actually the fun part
because you knowing like
nobody's in everybody's top five right
it's not no rap [ __ ] that's really
like you could go across there's about
50 [ __ ] in this room
like you you could go ask any of them
the top five is gonna all be
all be different yeah and that's just
like it is what it is man
everybody ain't gonna like the same
restaurant everybody ain't gonna like
the same that's lebron ain't gonna be
the best and everybody's top five jordan
ain't gonna be the right
right right like it is what it is but
that's the [ __ ] like
what if i can get to a point to where
you're anybody you ask his dog is like
yo
conway is the best we've ever seen so
that's what you're
striving for that's the [ __ ] that keeps
you up that night
you know you're here i mean look if you
put if you can pull that
[ __ ] off these albums and all these if
you could pull that [ __ ] off then
you'll pull something that nobody's
pulled off yeah i mean
yeah exactly because then that's the
undisputed exactly you know what i'm
saying
because they're because yo think about
we were talking about jordan i don't
think you'll find anyone who would ever
not have jordan in their top five in the
top five right
like what let's get to a point where
like something's like now lebron to go
nah jordan no no i think i think but i
think i think when we're talking about
top five
you you would be hard-pressed to find
anybody who knows anything about
basketball say that jordan wasn't in
their top five 100
now you might find some people who said
lebron wasn't but those are they're
haters
how what's your lebron thoughts
definitely
okay all right i just gotta make sure
i'm not gonna save
i didn't say i hate her because they
don't got brown and they top fire
because
something like the nba as well as like
rap man there's so many incredible
players yeah for sure i'll be thinking
all the time like
yeah how many players don't get like
devin booker and dame lillard and all
these guys that we don't
they don't even get the love that they
deserve because they're playing at the
same time as steph curry in
and giannis and you know james harden
and [ __ ] like
that's some real [ __ ] so um with this
album like
uh is this kind of like a
you know a layover until we get the
shady records project
is this like i like the way you put that
that's exactly it's the layover
it's a layover man you know what i'm
saying you know you lay over man you
gotta
you got a one-hour layover in buffalo
man you know what i'm saying
and and you know that's what this album
really is man this is
uh i'm just having fun i'm just rapping
you know what i'm saying like with no
care like i was just saying earlier like
you know i mean you know in 2019 and
2020 like
i i was driving myself crazy
trying to trying to win that you know
i should be on the on the list why i
ain't going to let you know
this year and going forward i'm not
spending no more energy
you know what i'm saying dwelling on
that or tripping on that [ __ ] you feel
me
i'm just i'm just having fun i'm just
being trying to just be
free free my mind and just get back to
the
to the front of this [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying the the rapping of it
you know what i'm saying and it's partly
a lot of it is
from working with someone you know the
artist and [ __ ] that i work with
you know what i'm saying you know these
[ __ ] inspire me like i'll be
hearing this [ __ ] you saying about the
artists on your label or just in general
yeah
in general yeah you know man like some
of the collabs i'm doing the features
and [ __ ]
and they could send me in and all that
you know i'm saying it it
you know it definitely inspired me man
because i've been you know the last few
months
i want to say since like november
probably even before that man but i just
got a
you know i know how to like keep [ __ ]
bottled in and all that [ __ ] affect me
on the surface
because i want my energy to affect
nobody else or
nobody else day and none of that [ __ ]
but like my mind ain't really i ain't
really been in
it i know this [ __ ] man like you know
what i'm saying so
you know i mean i i you know the people
that reached out to me for a feature
and you know the artists that i'm
working with now on this drone where
[ __ ]
they probably don't have no idea how
much what they're doing for you
yeah you know what i'm saying that the
state keep my blades sharpened
and still hang on to that love i got
from this hip-hop [ __ ]
yeah i'm saying yeah um what was the
last collab that got sent over to you
that kind of
helped help inspire you a bit
uh
really like i said all of them shits but
um
when i did that juicy j joint when juicy
jason [ __ ] over
and that [ __ ] just took me it just
because i was like
like wait a minute juicy jay won me on
right
right right he sent me three
you know i'm saying that uh like yeah
i mean get on one of them shits whatever
one you [ __ ] with
so i did two of the three beats i was
gonna do the third one right
right just to be like kind of like you
know what i'm saying but i did those two
and like right then and there on the
spot like maybe like
that hour hour or two just breaking and
i had both of them both of them shits
both of them shit's done and um i kind
of just like lost my zone that third one
but i sent them [ __ ] in
but like just hearing them and hearing a
response from me
rapping on [ __ ] like that and yeah hell
yeah like that [ __ ] kind of like that's
that was one of the ones like
okay let me let me let me let me get in
my bag man i'm playing
yeah i feel like any time i see you on
someone else's [ __ ]
i feel like you come extra crazy
like that like that jid record you you
went in on that [ __ ] man
and he's also someone who's [ __ ]
incredibly talented
that's my [ __ ] i don't be wanna let
[ __ ] down man oh cause you know what
they're coming to you for
like yo like you know what i'm saying
like they're coming to you
because they know what you what you
bring to that guest version
and i would hate for me to send a [ __ ]
some [ __ ]
and then he sent it back and that [ __ ]
ain't any you know man
and then you're right i hate to have to
tell them like yeah this ain't making
the cut
hey i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we got
to interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all talks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssocksofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving
is they got the naruto and i'm not even
into that [ __ ]
but the socks are fly and the street
fighter socks crazy licenses
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
right now save 20 off at checkout you uh
played me some [ __ ] earlier
uh with russ that's not out
um russ is obviously someone who's
tapped in with griselda i mean benny was
supposed to go on tour with him
um uh
you know i think i think when people
like russ who we don't really kind of
expect to like
have his ear to the street and mind you
i'm a rust fan i know russ so i know
better than that but i think that the
perception is
amongst like generic hip-hop fans is
that that's not the case
i think he shot shut a lot of those
people up with that chomp project yeah
but talk about him reaching out to you
um because he's obviously had a
relationship with benny
um but like like him tapping in with you
like
you know how that how'd that happen man
it was dope man
you know i think um
you know on the instagram it you know we
chopped it up on the gram and
exchanged numbers and you know what i'm
saying and
we kind of like just you know keep in
touch and [ __ ]
and you know that's a cool [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and
you show love you know i'm saying i show
love and
when he sent me to join he was like yo i
gotta join man i think you know i mean
it'd be crazy we could [ __ ] them up
right quick
and i'm like yo send that [ __ ] through
and you know what i mean
oh yeah you blacked out that's that's
something else like
[ __ ] don't be understanding like when
[ __ ] reach out to me
and like send me records and like have
me in mind to get on they [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] just like
it brings out the sometimes i'll be
forgetting who i am
you know what i mean like i'll be
forgetting like yo i'm really like the
machine like people
people [ __ ] with me people like
sometimes my [ __ ] shouldn't be having
to tell me like yo bro like get your
yo you got to get outside bro you got to
move around
[ __ ] with you right like you you're the
machine right right
right and i was saying like so it's like
cause i get into like my little you know
what i mean like damn this [ __ ] russ
wanna do a joint with i mean yeah
on the joint brother [ __ ] crazy you know
what i'm saying so that [ __ ]
that should always take me there like
i'm saying so when he sent that
i was like damn like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] with my
[ __ ] [ __ ] with my flow like i mean
yeah nah it's crazy too in that verse
you had mentioned something
that i think i heard you mentioned
before
it might have been
uh you you talked about the essentially
the people who hit in protest just to
take an instagram photo
right like that's something i feel like
you might have talked about on another
record
i feel like there was a record where you
kind of had a conscious take last year
that we had talked about i don't know if
was it a jim jones record was it
was it but no i'm trying to think i did
i did a lot i did a lot last year
but yeah it's crazy because we we in
2021 now you know i think last year you
know the country went through a lot you
know what i'm saying
but i didn't i do notice nowadays like
it's a lot of fake woke ass
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
yeah it's like that woke [ __ ] turns into
a trend is it it's
it's just trendy yeah
and then it's kind of spinning to like
just the cancel culture [ __ ] that's
going on
yes it's like man it's like people are
really out here
like looking for opportunities just to
look good on instagram and or
just to [ __ ] on somebody's life it felt
like that's that's what it feels like
and that's where that that you know that
line came from that bar came from
you know i mean it do feel like that you
know
but you know i just my my business man i
stay out of the
the politics and all that [ __ ] you know
i mean i i use my voice through
action you know i'm saying i i've
received like you know
proclamations in the city yeah erie
county legislative
you know what i mean and the mayor and
all type of you know you don't got to
advertise with you
yeah yeah and a lot of you by example i
don't even post all the things that i've
done
right right right you know what i'm
saying because that ain't what i do it
for like
i always hated them typing [ __ ] that
[ __ ] see a [ __ ] homeless and
[ __ ] in front of them
i mean and they [ __ ] videotape them
giving them money or something yeah it's
like what are you doing
while they're handing them a dollar and
[ __ ] like i'll always hated [ __ ] like
that
and you know i don't care nobody like i
said like
i really don't care nobody think of what
i do
and all that [ __ ] i just always want to
be remembered for my character
and just being a real [ __ ] being solid
man and just always
i give i get my people the shirt on my
back man i just
i just got a big heart i don't know how
to tell people no sometimes
so you know i don't even remember
where the question was no no no i mean
you pretty much nailed it
you know what i'm saying um yo we was at
we we
we were at gun store earlier you know
you got the uh the buffalo kids gallery
which was a very impressive place that
should fly that [ __ ] is crazy
um but we were kind of making fun of the
fact that
uh there's been this narrative about you
know
you benny and him kind of growing apart
drifting apart
you know etc and how funny it was like
did those conversations that happen
online do they ever like get
frustrating because it's obviously not
the case you know what i mean like
is it ever somewhere you're just like yo
what the [ __ ] like people are bored or
what
honestly you know what i'm saying
you know they people love griselda man
like
you know this griselda [ __ ] man this
thing we built
we ain't even see it being well i
knew without you know it was going to be
special and that we was going to be like
you know what i'm saying you know i knew
it was going to work and i knew because
i knew
i've always believed in what was
bringing to the table and the talent
but i don't even think me and wes knew
what this [ __ ] was gonna be when we
started this [ __ ] up you know what i'm
saying and um
some fans love us man more than we know
sometimes you know what i'm saying and
um
so yes concerns man genuine concerns and
questions from fans like
you know when they seeing certain little
[ __ ] from the outside looking in that's
probably
not the norm from what they what they're
used to
for yes you know what i'm saying and
you know a couple of my tweets
that i i put out there probably didn't
help things
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah they
might have thrown a log on the fire
yeah and um
you know but the truth of the matter is
we
we have grown apart man you know what
i'm saying like we ain't
you know what i'm saying we're not
really the young boys no more
you know just hanging out and you know
chasing a dream
and we all like like grown grown ass men
with families and you know
responsibilities and people to take care
of and
we have everybody got their own brands
and other things that they
you know expanding and and and [ __ ]
with two that you know time is
is very limited you know what i mean you
might not see us together all the time
you might not hear us on the same album
all the time [ __ ] might just genuinely
didn't have time to get the verse done
right [ __ ] might just genuinely didn't
have time to pull up to the
show right it just you know i mean like
we getting
you know man this gazelle this [ __ ] is
getting bigger than what we even would
have thought so
you know i could see where that you know
the you know
the questions and concerns come from
from like the fans and [ __ ]
but i'm gonna keep it a thousand two
like this is real [ __ ] check
real [ __ ] time like some of my tweets
and [ __ ] probably didn't help
um he's there you know their concerns
right right right right and the funny
[ __ ] is like some of my tweets it was
like
mo all of them says really just like
some of them just was like
just like verses i wrote like bars
right that i written and you know
wasn't even nothing that i thought in my
mind like
would get taken that way right right
right right because i'm not no
internet dude like i don't even really
right i'm not the guy that's just going
to just be having twitter like just
going crazy on twitter like
you know what you know we we
family in real life so that don't go
away
forever yeah i think too like it's
unfair for fans to not expect you and
benny to grow your own brands
and like you know what i'm saying like
and and to level up your own [ __ ]
right because at the end of the day like
like you said it in a in
on a record where you were like uh
yeah west owns the land but i did the
construction but now you got your own
land and you do and you know what i'm
saying
and it's drum work you know what i mean
and benny's got bsf
and that don't mean that rick hyde ain't
fam
and you know everybody's everybody's in
the next room
you know what i'm saying i met rick with
you for the first time
yeah so you know what i'm saying so it's
like i just think like
i think a lot of uh hip-hop fans are
conditioned
that our favorite groups never last and
i know you guys aren't necessarily a
group
but you know we came up and wu-tang had
their issues and
and dip said obviously you know like a
lot of our favorite groups
didn't necessarily you know last as long
as we like but i think that
with you guys i'm not sure that that's
the case i just think it's like you said
it's just natural gross
natural growth you guys are all popping
as [ __ ] all busy as [ __ ]
we have a businesses we have an artist
that we got to work with
and and get them you know off and
running and all that [ __ ] and
you know it's just it's just it's just
business it's just life we grown man
but you know it's just interesting too
because like
you know we never we we're not a group
you know what i'm saying
right we was a group like when shingon
was alive we was
you guys are a label yeah but we turned
into a label like everybody was their
own
entity they artists like
y'all got nominated for best hip-hop
group at the bt awards though it's crazy
yeah
awful not being a group yeah just
we just all collabed on the tape you
know what i'm saying so i didn't even
think about that like that that's the
fact
that's crazy right like we weren't even
a group we got nominated for over the
years
we just collapsed on some records and
you know
but you know i mean we're together
stronger
and we always going to be strong dog and
you know them that's family bro and this
you know what i mean they own an album
we got an incredible record on
final final song in the album right i
think it's the last record
i look at the track listen today i think
i think it might be the last one yeah i
forget
yeah um i'm curious man because uh
you and i are similar in age and i know
how much dmx meant to me coming up and
you know he's going through
his health situation and hopefully you
know what what did x mean to you
like from
he passed
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up man
that [ __ ] x man x was a legend man
that dude was like a superhero to me as
a kid man like
i always always thought like you know
what i'm saying nobody could really [ __ ]
with x
like like no cap like i always thought
like you know those [ __ ] that i
probably like you know
albums and [ __ ] who i might have liked
more and all i said but i'm just saying
like
face to face if x pull up on you
you know what i'm saying you're not
[ __ ] with x man let me tell you
something when i was a kid i was 12 i
went to the hard knock life tour
and i left after dmx got off the stage i
did not even stay
max man i did not stay for jay-z's
performances
he did that prayer [ __ ] [ __ ] couldn't
[ __ ] with x man no hype man no
nothing bro i was so rough write it out
as a kid i used to tag up that r
on my [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] true man rest
in peace axe man recipes dark man x man
that's tough man damn [ __ ] [ __ ] up too
man we didn't join we just want his
hours and better drop a new album
you guys got a record together that was
supposed to come out on the new album
yeah
damn down there record that [ __ ] winning
swiss joint how was that experience man
i didn't get to see him bro i never got
a chance to meet x in my life
you ever talked to him on the phone or
but he was he had been a fan to get you
on the album
yeah i seen him on the clip but um benny
was down there with him and nori and all
that
listening to [ __ ] and all that so he met
benny
i don't know if wes met him but i never
met i never met the og man and
um and being on that record i was dying
to
i just i was i was hoping that [ __ ]
would be there
flew to atlanta get in the studio but he
was like sick or some [ __ ] he didn't
make it that night you know what i mean
so we just did our verses and left but
damn man i hope that [ __ ] you know man
that's crazy man
i don't even know how to react right
neither do i man that's wild
dmx my when i was for about two years of
my life as a kid he was my favorite
rapper in the world man
that's right too that's [ __ ] wild
i don't even know where to go from here
really like
um well look your album's coming out
r.i.p the dmx man
that's crazy [ __ ]
um just [ __ ] me up that [ __ ] me up
too
anything else you want to say man
yeah man it really don't feel right to
talk about anything else
that's crazy yeah rest in peace to the
dog man
think about that two album run stark in
hell is hot flesh of my flesh blood on
my blood
both in the same year come on man
oh number ones come on he brought hey
when did he had the shiny shoes popping
dmx came shut all that [ __ ] down bro
oh my god
damn yo it was crazy man i was a kid
when uh
when big ian popped you know saying
when that [ __ ] happened like so i didn't
really know how to get out but this [ __ ]
this this this [ __ ] me out right here
yeah man we'll rest in peace to dmx man
that you know um conway got an album
coming out next week
yeah yeah yeah yeah like now man
dropping that [ __ ] april 16th man there
it is